FRANCESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
57 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy, and I'm here
with my colleague Mark Mandel.
Hey, Mark.
How are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I'm good.
Happy New Year!
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Happy New
Year, to you and to you all
people listening everywhere
around the world.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, and
we're back again for 2017.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
And we're back again
with some incredibly
amazing episode.
I know that you're very
excited about this one.
MARK MANDEL: It's pretty cool.
We're talking to
Edward Wu from Niantic
about Pokemon Go
in this episode.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It's
pretty exciting.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Quick
question, are you more excited
about this episode, or the
episode with John Wilks?
MARK MANDEL: So, I
feel like you can't
compare two beautiful sunsets.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Do you
love more Mom or Dad?
MARK MANDEL: How do you
compare two beautiful sunsets?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: I
don't think you can.
They are both unique and
wonderful in their own ways.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I know.
I'm very, very excited
about this episode, too.
There's so much to learn
about the whole experience
that they went through.
So, yeah.
And we're going to discuss
all the interesting things
that they went through, all
the Pokemons that were cut,
and stuff like that.
MARK MANDEL: Yup.
And then once we're
done with that,
we have a question of the
week about encryption keys.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Which is pretty cool, because
actually the answer is
related to something new, too.
So, a very interesting
question and answer.
But before that, we have
the cool things of the week.
The first cool
things of the week.
And we had to choose
only three out
of the many, many,
many things that
happened during the holidays.
But we will spend our time,
the future weeks basically,
going over all the cool
things that happened.
MARK MANDEL: I don't understand.
You figure that people shut
down over that period, but no.
Apparently, we were
just like let's really
sell a whole bunch of stuff.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
They work harder.
It's like, please,
people, chill.
Anyway, the first
one is this blog post
that was that is part of the
Google Cloud Platform blog
post on how we secure
our infrastructure.
As in, how we secure our
own Google Cloud Platform
infrastructure.
So the blog post is a
pretty short blog post
but it actually points
to a security zine
white paper that is
definitely worth reading.
It has-- I really like that
it starts with a CIO level
summary.
So there's basically the four
points that you care about,
what they are going
to be talking about.
But you can go into
it in more detail,
and see how we protect you
against, like, DDoS attacks,
or how encryption arrest
works, and how deletion of data
happens.
This is like so much stuff.
There's all of those
security layers,
and it goes in to detail on
every single one of them.
So it's definitely worth--
as a curiosity, really.
But if you are
interested in security,
it's definitely a
good paper to read.
MARK MANDEL: Actually,
it's worth noting, really,
this is like the beginning of a
series of stuff around security
and identity that are going
to be happening on the blog.
So definitely stay tuned
if that's your thing
and you're really concerned
about security and identity.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
And if you're not concerned
about security, you should.
No, but it's a very interesting
white paper nonetheless.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
So the next one is--
I don't know why, this
just makes me really happy.
I know a lot of people have
wanted this for a while.
We now have actual icons and
simple architectural diagrams
for designing stuff.
Like, when you're building
out your architecture
on Google Cloud
Platform, and you
want to design it
out using either,
say, Google Slides, or
Lucidchart, or PowerPoint,
or if you just need
PNGs or SVGs to put
inside your favorite
diagramming software.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: We have those
now available to use!
So you can use them, which I
think is actually really handy.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: I'm incredibly
excited about it, because I--
like, it is sad to say, but
very often I would Google--
I would Search on Google
for our own products
to find that I could--
MARK MANDEL: Exactly.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: --you
know, our own presentations.
I'm very happy that we
finally got a repository.
And it is open, so
anyone can use it.
So if you're thinking
about talking
about how you use Google Cloud
Platform on a presentation,
feel free to go and use them.
MARK MANDEL: Definitely.
Now, we have one more.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, one
more cool thing of the week.
And this one is really cool to
start with because, of course,
it's written in Go.
But also because it
is about something
that many people have
asked me about how
to do it, which is, how do
you do continuous deployment
to Google Cloud Platform?
Specifically, how do you
do continuous deployment
to App Engine and
Container Engine?
And turns out the
New York Times,
they have been using Google
Platform for quite a while.
They had this issue,
and they solved it.
And they open
sourced the project.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
it's pretty cool.
There's a New-- sorry,
there's an open source
continuous integration and
continuous deployment platform
called Drone that's
written in Go.
And they built plugins
for GKE and GAE,
so you can do continuous
delivery and deployment
to those two platforms.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It's pretty cool.
It's all built
around Containers.
Yay Containers.
We all love Containers.
And it's pretty neat.
So, super happy to see the
community and the ecosystem
around Google Cloud
Platform continue to grow.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It is definitely worth it.
So check it out.
We have a link on the show
next to the blog post,
but also to the GitHub repost.
You can go and read the code
directly, which is very nice.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
Well, why don't we go
talk to-- hee hee hee hee.
Why don't we go talk
to Ed about Pokemon Go?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
MARK MANDEL: So today, I am very
excited to have Edward Wu here
from Niantic joining
us on the podcast.
Ed, how are you doing today?
EDWARD WU: Very good.
Thank you very much
for having me here.
I'm really excited to be
able to talk about how
the past few months have gone.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, it's not
like you've been up to anything
special or exciting, or anything
like that that anyone would
have ever heard of or--
EDWARD WU: Nothing big.
MARK MANDEL: Nothing big.
Nothing at all.
EDWARD WU: Getting plenty
of sleep, of course, yes.
MARK MANDEL: Of course.
Excellent.
Cool, so, before we go into
the magic of Pokemon Go,
do you want to tell us a little
bit about you, and who you are,
and what you do?
EDWARD WU: Sure.
I'm director of software
engineering here at Niantic.
I actually lead the Pokemon
Go engineering team.
Done so since we spun out of
Google in October of 2015,
and all the way through
the launch of Pokemon Go
last summer, all the
way through to today.
And in addition to managing
the engineering and publication
of Pokemon Go, I
also product manage
portions of our technology
platform, which I'd
be happy to speak about later.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So, I heard something
that surprised me
in listening to one of
my favorite podcasts
which is not this one.
99% Invisible.
I heard about this ship
below the [INAUDIBLE]
here in San Francisco,
called the Niantic.
Is there any relationship?
EDWARD WU: Yeah, that's kind
of what our company is named
after, and what our
autonomous unit while we were
inside Google was named after.
It's a ship that
actually ran aground--
they ran aground during the
gold rush era of San Francisco.
People were so excited to--
I'm sure that they decided
just to run it aground
and turn it into a hotel
rather than continuing
to sail it back and forth.
And I think the sense of
adventure, hence discovery,
is part of what our
CEO and founder John
was trying to evoke there.
MARK MANDEL: So you
mentioned just a bit
there, like, Niantic
spun out of Google.
Do you want to give
us a little background
of Niantic the company?
I think it's got kind of
a little unique history.
EDWARD WU: Yeah, it's got
a really unique history.
So, our CEO and CTO--
our CEO John Hanke and
our CTO Phil Keslin
are actually veterans
of a previous startup
that was acquired by
Google called Keyhole.
Keyhole made a
product which turned
into what most people know
as Google Earth today.
And so while they were
in Google, they were--
this was the age when, you
know, the very first set
of smartphones began to
get out into the market,
so things like Google's
Nexus One phone.
And they looked at
these things, and they
saw that the majority of
entertainment and experiences
on them were things
like Angry Birds.
Which, while it was novel from
like an input perspective,
was not particularly making full
use of the insane capabilities
that having a computer
carried around in your pocket
could provide, right?
These things are loaded with
location sensors, and network
capabilities, and
advanced processing power.
They really thought
there was something
that they could do to
make unique experiences
with these devices that,
since they were portable,
actually got people outside,
got people to meet each other,
got people to
explore their world,
got people more engaged
with their communities.
They started investigating
a variety of product ideas
which could actually
go towards that goal.
And they came up with two,
which are-- both were quite
informative both from a
product and technology
perspective for what eventually
would become Pokemon Go.
So while we were in Google,
we launched two products.
One is called Fieldtrip, which
used the location sensors
on your phone to make local
recommendations of really
interesting sites that
might be around you that you
might want to check out.
The other was a game called
Ingress, which is something
that, if you play Pokemon
Go and then go back to,
you'll recognize
large elements there.
There's a resource collection
mechanic on the move.
There are points of
interest in the game,
that the game tries
to drive you towards.
So, interesting local
historical monuments, or art,
or small interesting
local businesses.
And this game, just
like Pokemon Go,
is a location based game
that tries to actually get
people to interact out in
the real world together using
a single consistent gameboard.
And so we were actually
quite successful
in getting a lot of
attention on Ingress.
And one of the bits of
attention was actually
the folks at the
Pokemon Company, who
saw this game that was
actually getting people out
into the real world,
that was actually
getting them to meet others and
explore the local communities.
It was actually kind of a
perfect fit, thematically,
for the way that Pokemon has
been throughout its entire IP
lifetime.
And so, we decided
to spin out of Google
as an independent
company, partnering
with Nintendo and the Pokemon
Company to create Pokemon Go.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so,
you said that with Niantic you
got a little bit of attention.
I'd say that with Pokemon Go you
got a little bit of attention,
too.
It was kind of a big deal.
Could you give us a little bit
an idea of how big of a deal
it was.
Like, we've heard everyone
saying that it was huge.
How huge was it?
EDWARD WU: Yeah,
so, as of December--
I crunch the statistics
every so often with the help
of the engineering team here.
We take a look at not only the
kind of more technical numbers,
but some product driven ones.
So, we've actually had
people walk more than 8.7
billion kilometers, which for
a sense of scale is past Pluto.
And I think it's about 200,000
times around the Earth.
And we've had 88-- more than
88 billion Pokemon caught
by our players, collectively.
So just to give you the
sheer sense of scale--
I mean, it's almost
beyond comprehension.
The collective
effort that people
put into not only playing
this game, but actually,
when you think about
all that walking,
is the exercise and exploration
and meeting of new people
that they've done
in the midst of it.
From a more technical
perspective,
to give you an idea of how
much bigger this was than what
we expected, it was roughly 50
times greater than the capacity
that we actually had
planned for at launch.
And that's actually a story
I'd be happy to go into,
because it was--
it goes to the heart
of why the Google Cloud
team was such an instrumental
part of our success.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So before
when we go into more details,
I had a quick question above
those 88 billion Pokemon
caught.
How many of them were Pidgeys?
EDWARD WU: I think a significant
fraction, but actually--
people play the game for
different reasons, right?
I think some people
go and they try
to catch every Pidgey
in sight, because it
gets them some stardust which
will allow them to power
up their other Pokemon.
Other people try
to pick and choose.
So I don't think that the--
the distribution that
you see on the screen
is not necessarily
the distribution
that people actually
end up catching.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: OK.
Interesting.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right.
So, yeah, let's get stuck into
the technical side of these,
because I think this is
absolutely fascinating.
You mentioned, as well--
obviously if you've
played in Ingress before,
you can see elements
of that in Pokemon Go.
Did you end up using the
same stuff that you used,
the same products
that used in Ingress?
Or did you take lessons
learned from Ingress
and change certain things?
Like, what was different
between the two products,
and what lessons did
you learn between them?
EDWARD WU: From a technical
architectural standpoint,
the major transition
that we made
was from App Engine, which was a
previous generation of Google's
Cloud computing products,
to Google Container engine.
Which was something that
only came out of a few years
after Ingress had started.
And so, we did take
the opportunity
to modernize some of our
technical infrastructure.
Be happy to go a
bit into that later.
But many of the core algorithms,
and many of the key--
both engineering learnings
that we took away
from how Ingress operated, as
well as product lessons that we
took away, greatly informed
how we implemented Pokemon Go.
MARK MANDEL: So, you mentioned
sort of, you modernized stuff.
I believe you are using
Kubernetes behind the scenes
rather than the App Engine.
EDWARD WU: Yes.
MARK MANDEL: What
drove that decision?
EDWARD WU: So, App Engine
came from a different era
of Google's Cloud services,
where things ran in a sandbox.
And it made it--
App Engine, as a
product, is actually
quite good for getting
something out the door
really, really quickly.
Not having to worry about
whether your front ends
will scale.
Not having to worry about
exactly what you're--
having full control
of your service loop.
It's kind of a plug and
play for web services.
And so, we initially-- we
implemented Ingress on that
because that was what Google
had available five years back
or so.
And it worked quite well for
us to begin to understand,
how does running a game
where everybody in the world
actually has to share a single
consistent view of that world?
What kind of
technical trade-offs
do you need to make in
order to make that happen
in near real time, delivered
through the latency
of a mobile connection?
So App Engine was great for the
time that Ingress was launched.
Now, as we moved
on to Pokemon Go,
we wanted to modernize
our architecture a bit.
And the major difference between
Kubernetes and App Engine
is that Kubernetes
gives you something
that's much closer to a
raw machine, in a sense.
You can run your own--
you can literally run Java Main
and start up your own server
there, and take inbound
network traffic,
and configure it to your liking.
In fact, we spun out of Google.
Many of us are Google engineers.
And Kubernetes actually
reassembles, very,
very strongly, the kind
of internal infrastructure
that we were used to
as Google engineers.
All of the ability to
define services that
ran very close to Bare Metal.
It had all the
flexibility of being
able to interact very
closely with the operating
system and the network stack.
But still was abstracted enough
away from the Bare Metal,
such that we could rapidly
scale the number of instances
if necessary.
So what Kubernetes eventually,
and Google Container Engine
gave us, was all
that flexibility
of scaling and deployment
that App Engine did,
plus much more technical
flexibility for us
to define our own binaries.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So, keeping on the
topic of your stack,
you mentioned Java
Main which kind of
made me sad, because
I was wondering
if Pokemon Go was
actually written
in Go in any piece of it.
EDWARD WU: Just the HUD.
Just for the name
of the product.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Could you tell us,
is everything written in Java?
What languages are you using?
EDWARD WU: So, the server
stack is more or less Java.
And, as former Google engineers,
and being part of the industry
standard, Java really I think
was the right decision for us
to make.
It allowed us to iterate
very, very quickly
on gameplay concepts, as well
as bring in existing code
that we had from
Ingress and port it over
from App Engine to
Container Engine,
since Java was one of the
supported languages on App
Engine.
So, the other thing that
Java allowed us to do
was, because it's an industry
standard language, was
it allowed us to bring the
best and brightest of server
engineers who wanted to work
on a product like Pokemon Go
into Niantic.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So, one of the things
that surprised me
was, I saw that you
were using Datastore.
And at the same time, you have
the biggest Kubernetes cluster
in the world.
Or at least, when we announced
it, it was the biggest one.
MARK MANDEL: As far as
we were aware, anyway.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So
I was wondering--
I mean, you definitely
had space to run
the database on the Kubernetes
cluster, it's so big.
Why didn't you do it?
Why did you go with Datastore?
EDWARD WU: So, there's
some prior experience
that we had with Datastore.
But that was not determinative.
So, Datastore was pretty much
our only option for Ingress,
because again, App Engine is
this quick framework, which
allows you to not have to worry
about implementing a database,
doesn't make you worry about
setting up of your own web
servlet binary et cetera.
But, the price that
you pay is that you
have to go with the chosen
storage technology, which
in that case was Datastore.
Now, that being said,
Datastore was an--
is an awesome technology.
And that's why we
actually-- when
we made the transition from
App Engine to Container Engine,
we evaluated a variety
of different options.
Being able to stand up our
own relational database,
or using some other
cloud based [INAUDIBLE]
provider was definitely other
options that we looked at.
But we kept coming
back to Datastore.
And the reason that we
stuck with Datastore
was because it scales
almost indefinitely
from doing individual
development
as an individual developer
on a test instance,
all the way up to games at
the scale of Pokemon Go.
And it scales seamlessly.
You don't need to do any
configuration changes.
At least on our side,
on the developer side,
we didn't need to do any
configuration changes.
We didn't need to do
any kind of futzing
with routing, or futzing with
scaling the database back ends,
or anything.
All we had to do was
program against the set
of transactional APIs.
And what we got in return
was multi NTT transactions
that were consistent
and distributed.
That we didn't have to
worry about making sure
were backed up or replicated.
And advanced indexing
capabilities which go to--
which we use at both the heart
of both Ingress and Pokemon Go.
And so after taking a
look at a lot of options--
maybe using like a
sorted MySQL instance,
or using a different third
party NoSQL provider.
We really thought
that Datastore had
the most advanced combination
of the scale of the multi NTT
transactions for
a NoSQL datastore,
as well as advanced indexing
capabilities and ease
of use and maintenance that
were just unparalleled.
And frankly, were a key
part of our success.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, that's super cool.
So, I know we've talked
about GKE and Datastore.
And those are the only
products you're using?
Are you able to talk
about anything else
that you've used that's
on Google Cloud Platform
or across Google?
EDWARD WU: Yes, absolutely.
So, one of the benefits of
having worked at Google,
and being former
Google engineers,
is that we've actually seen
the progression of tools
that Google created for its
own internal engineering
progressively propagated out as
Google Cloud Platform products.
And one of the ones that
I really want to highlight
is Google Cloud Bigtable.
We loved working
with of Bigtable
as engineers within Google.
It was-- it's a key part
of many, many, many Google
systems.
And its debut as
an external service
is for completely different
use cases that for Datastore.
Datastore we use
for transactions,
whereas Bigtable is more for
bulk storage and bulk data
processing.
And it's been an
incredible product
to actually have on the outside.
And I hope that Google
continues to push
more and more of the
awesome internal tools
that we loved as
engineers in Google,
out to the Cloud platform.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, we
cannot confirm nor deny.
But, yes.
I've think that there's
more coming, yeah.
EDWARD WU: Awesome.
MARK MANDEL: OK, cool.
This'll probably segue
actually quite nicely to,
you talked about how
with Datastore, you
didn't have to do any changes to
handle the amount of throughput
that was coming through.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, that's a
very subtle way of putting it.
MARK MANDEL: I thought
that was quite--
I thought that was quite cute.
But I know we have announced the
Cluster Reliability Engineering
Team, the CRE Team,
and they basically
started interacting
with you as a customer.
How was that experience?
Like, how did that go?
What was that like?
EDWARD WU: So, I think here
is actually a good time
to go through the whole
story of the launch,
because it's directly relevant
to how that interaction was
so helpful.
So, we did our homework
before we launched Pokemon Go.
I swear we did.
We went and we looked
at the launches
for other mobile games.
Top two mobile games, right,
ones with established IPs,
ones that were sequels
of really popular games
in the past couple of years.
And we looked at--
from publicly available
business intelligence,
what the number of--
what their growth
curves would look like.
What the number of users that
they would have would look
like.
And we used those numbers,
and our experience on Ingress,
to extrapolate from the
product driven numbers,
like monthly and
daily active users,
to what we thought would
be the load on our servers
and on Cloud Datastore
at any given time.
And our Cloud Datastore team
leading up to our launch
was great.
They were constantly
in touch with us,
helping us with upgrades to
the APIs, or fixes for things
that we didn't understand
when we encountered them.
And they also asked,
quite reasonably,
so what do you think your
capacity for launch will be?
So we extrapolated it from all
of those numbers, to what we
thought was a reasonable number.
And then we multiplied
the reasonable number
by like five times, and
said this is ludicrous.
Nobody will ever have to go
five times bigger than anything
else that's out there.
And we'll ask Datastore
to set that aside for us.
So we launched the game on
the evening of July 5th.
So July 4th is, of course, a
holiday in the United States.
We were lucky enough to actually
get everything squared away
before the holiday weekend.
And so I had everybody go
and have barbecues and watch
fireworks with their families.
And we came in rearing on
July 5th, ready to launch.
And the way that we
were going to launch
was that we started out with
Australia and New Zealand.
These are markets
that we could watch
that were in another time
zone, and that we could
see through the evening as to
how they progressed before we
moved on to more populated areas
of the world the United States.
And what ended up happening
was, we immediately-- like,
it looks like a delta
function spike, right?
Like, we immediately
blew past the 1x number,
the kind of baseline
estimate for the whole world
that we thought
we were going to--
we were going to be at, right?
Just in Australia
and New Zealand.
And we were well on our way to
that ludicrous 5x number by--
just from just from
Australia and New Zealand.
Mind you, Australia
and New Zealand
we expected, from other product
launches of other business
intelligence in
the mobile market,
to be single digit
percentages, at most,
of the entire world
wide active user base.
And it is at this point that we
call up our friends at Google
and said, well, you know those
estimates that we gave you?
Few Those were great.
We might need to go
a little bit higher.
MARK MANDEL: Rats.
EDWARD WU: Haha.
And it turned out that over the
course of the next few weeks
as we launched across all of--
first the United States the
day after Australia and New
Zealand, and then progressively
around the rest of the world,
that we ended up eventually
needing something
on order of 50 times
the initial capacity
estimate so we gave
to Cloud Datastore.
MARK MANDEL: Just a little bit.
EDWARD WU: So just a little bit.
So, that team was instrumental
in working with us to make sure
that that could happen.
I know that pulling
that off, basically
within two weeks between
our initial launches
to launch in Japan
and then further
on into the rest of the
month throughout Southeast
Asia and Latin America-- pulling
that off required a lot of work
on the Google side.
I don't think that
they'd ever seen
anything of this magnitude
come through a single customer
service.
And so I know that
they did a lot of work
to rearrange internal
resources, and move things
around in their data
centers to make sure
that they could support
us all along the way.
And during all of that, we
didn't have to-- like I said,
we didn't have to change
anything in our APIs, right?
We didn't have to reconfigure
any kind of routing system.
Or, we didn't have to change
the type of transactions.
We just kept on plugging on
doing what we were doing,
fixing our bugs,
and fixing anything
that we had in our own
servers, that we had
to work out to get to scale.
And the Datastore
team did everything
that they could to support us.
And so one of the things I'm
really proud of, is that--
in fact, I think the separation
was actually full and complete.
Google engineers never took
a look into our code base.
We never invited them to.
They never needed to.
The layer of the API abstraction
was complete and perfect.
And I'm very proud of how we
eventually ended up scaling.
I know the first few
days, it was obviously
a little difficult to
get into the servers.
But it turns out that
our fundamental technical
architecture was sound.
And what our scaling bugs
were, were the kinds of things
that you'd normally run
across as you scale up
any web service.
So, typical debugging
looped looked to us like,
OK, well let's take a dump
of all the stack traces that
are running in the
server right now.
And oh, like maybe 75%
of them are caught up
on some silly mutex somewhere.
So you go and you do a full on
code change to fix the mutex.
And then throughput
shoots up on the server,
and then look for
the next bottleneck.
These are things that are very,
very routine for people who
deploy web services that scale.
The only difference
between them and us,
is that we had to do so on
the back of a rocket ship.
I think other folks get a little
bit of a gentler growth curve.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah, I have
an article right now next
to me saying that after
day two, you basically
reached the daily users of
Twitter, which is crazy.
Like, the amount of users that
you got so fast and scaling
that fast without having
to rewrite all your code.
I'm pretty sure that if
I have any of my demos
have to scale that much,
better rewrite the whole thing.
So that is pretty amazing.
EDWARD WU: Yeah, I can't
talk about daily users
in particular, unfortunately.
But obviously if I may,
one of the other key points
of the way that we scale
that I'm very, very proud of
is that these are just
isolated users working
in their own instance.
I think-- we'll get to the key
of why this is so important
later--
but ultimately Pokemon Go
a single consistent world
for everybody who plays on it.
If somebody
manipulates a Pokestop
and puts a lure on there,
everybody within about a
kilometer has to see
those pedals dropping
from the Pokestop.
If a few dozen people are
in the same park together
and there's a Squirtle
on one end of the park
and they're all
within range of it,
they all have to be able to see
that Squirtle at the same time.
Maintaining that
consistent world state
means that we have a variety
of, not just n scaling problems,
but n squared like
scaling problems.
I'm very proud that not only our
algorithms, but Google's Cloud
Platform, were
able to accommodate
those algorithms to scale
in such a fashion, which
I think is really a non-trivial
feat of engineering.
And it is entirely
empowered by the fact
that we were running on
Container Engine and Datastore,
and were able to basically
turn the knobs as necessary
with our binaries
on those platforms
in order to make that
n squared scaling work.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
I'm sure I'm going
to get deflected,
but I feel like I
should ask anyway.
So what can we expect for
the future of Pokemon Go?
EDWARD WU: So,
unfortunately I can't
talk about any particular
future product launches.
But we are working very,
very heavily on really,
a set of features that,
frankly, as a player,
I'm insanely excited about.
I will say that Ingress
is about four years old.
And during that time, we
have improved substantially.
I think in vast
swaths of the game
actually were not
there at launch.
So, things like the
Ingress mission system,
or the regional scoring system,
or player profile and badges.
All of this stuff was not
there when we initially
launched Ingress.
And we are committed to
these games for years,
because we know from Ingress--
we know that people actually
play them for years.
And so I'm very, very excited
to follow a similar trajectory
on Pokemon Go, to continue
to support and build up
major features in this game and
bring a lot more joy to people
as time goes on.
MARK MANDEL: So,
you've obviously
got a history of building mobile
location based experiences.
Is there plans to
expand upon that?
More products,
that sort of thing?
EDWARD WU: Absolutely.
So one of the great things
about moving to Container Engine
was that we took--
we took the opportunity while
we did so to also separate
our game logic from what I call
our core geospatial inquiry
logic.
And the Core geospatial
inquiry logic
and the way that we interact
with Google's Cloud platforms
are segregated into
a separate codebase.
Literally, we run to repos.
A platform repo, and then
a game specific repo.
So--
MARK MANDEL: Interesting.
EDWARD WU: We very
much want to make sure
that the way that we interact
with the Cloud platform
is nicely encapsulated, so that
we can very quickly scale out
our own internal teams to
try a variety of really
interesting new product ideas.
And we really believe that this
is a genre, an entire genre
of games that
actually is prob-- is
the future of what mobile and
AR gaming is going to look like.
And there are a lot of
great ideas out there.
And in order for us to be able
to rapidly iterate and try
to winnow them down
into our next product,
we absolutely need to be
able to abstract away the way
that we interact with Cloud
platform technologies.
And so, in the
creation of Pokemon Go,
we already took on
the vast majority
of the work necessary to do so.
And I'm really excited
to see what we're
going to come up with next.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, in
a more personal note,
I know that for me, Pokemon Go
actually changed a little bit
the way that-- like, I would
take the bus less often,
because the best goes too
fast, you cannot really catch
the Pokemon that easy.
So I've got walk
a little bit more.
What about you?
Is there-- like, I'm
curious about you,
since you lived it
from the inside.
What did Pokemon Go
change in your life?
EDWARD WU: Yeah, so, I will
say, on a personal note
my father plays this
game religiously.
And he's actually a level 31
trainer, which is amazing to me
because he hardly ever played
video games ever in the past.
And this is an incredibly
gratifying for me
personally, because
for the last,
I'd say dozen or
so years, he's been
managing his blood sugar
intake because of adult onset
diabetes.
And this game has gotten him
out walking daily, exploring
his neighborhood,
keeping up his exercise.
And it's gotten his
blood sugar to be as rock
solid and stable as ever.
I mean, it's incredible
to be able to have
that kind of effect.
And if you think about--
that's my father, of course.
That's incredibly near and
dear and personal to me.
But it's an incredibly
gratifying as an engineer
to realize that there must be
millions of people like him
out there, who are playing
this game, who are improving
their health, who
are finding out
more about their communities,
all because of code that--
not only that we wrote, but
that Google's Cloud Platform
empowers.
Ultimately, Google making
these services available
is a paradigm shift in the way
that single consistent world
gaming can actually
be engineered,
and can actually be deployed
and delivered to mobile phones.
And it's amazing to think
that we live in an era
where we can actually
drive substantial changes
in personal behavior
for the better,
based on what people
might think of as
dry technological concepts
like Container Engine.
When in fact, it's
actually quite exciting.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
That makes a lot of
sense, and I can totally
see why that is
very exciting, 100%.
So we are running out
of time, unfortunately.
I mean, we could talk for hours.
Is there anything we
haven't touched on,
or something you
want to mention?
I know Niantic is hiring.
Do you want to talk about that?
Like, what can we
wrap up with you?
EDWARD WU: Yeah, absolutely.
Niantic is hiring.
I think we really have a lot
of really great positions open.
Not only if you have experience
in large scale server or server
architecture, both
in C# and Java,
but also on the mobile
clients and device side.
You asked earlier about what
languages we program in, we
also program in Unity and C#,
because ultimately we have
a mobile client that's
beautiful, that's performant.
And that requires a lot of
not only Unity code, but also
mobile native code--
so C++, Java, Objective C--
in order to make happen.
I also want to plug one
other bit of where we're
going as a company, because I
think every part of the company
will feed into this.
So, one of the things
that we've invested a lot
into in the past--
as part of Pokemon Go,
is to Pokemon Go Plus,
which is this device that
you can actually wear
and that will help you play
the game alongside you.
So that you can actually
have experience playing
the game that doesn't
involve your mobile phone,
if you need a hands
off experience
while you're still
exploring the world
and playing the
game simultaneously.
We really think that, even
though the Pokemon Go Plus
is, right now, just a vibrating
button with some lights,
that it is a harbinger
of what hardware is going
to look like in the future.
And you can see from our very
first concept trailers for this
game, that we really, really
believe that there's going
to be-- from all of these
augmented reality hardware
products that people are
trying out right now,
things like Microsoft
Hololens, or Google's Tango--
all these different
technologies that people
are trying to put out
there to overlay things
on top of the real world--
that there will be
mobile technology
that integrates-- seamlessly
integrates the real world
with a virtual one.
And we are very excited to
be at the forefront of that.
I think we really demonstrated
that augmented reality
technology is not solely
about the hardware experience.
Although we are very
excited about integrating
those hardware experiences
as they come on line.
But we really believe that
augmented reality is just
as much about being able to
have a shared state with all
the people around you.
So that everybody who
participates in this reality,
really believes it at
a fundamental level.
You know, there's something
really magical about the idea
that when 10 people open
up their mobile phones
and see a Charizard
further down the block
together, that they all
orient that in their mind,
that they all believe
that together.
And we really believe that
shared social experience
is actually as much a
part of augmented reality
as the hardware
experiences will be.
And at its core, those
social experiences
are an n squared
problem that can only
be solved by operating on
a platform of Google Cloud.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
Well, thank you so much
for joining us today.
That was fascinating.
And I think our listeners are
going to really appreciate it.
EDWARD WU: Thank you very
much for the opportunity.
I really appreciate the chance
to talk to your listeners,
and I hope that they get
something out of this as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and hopefully-- you
said that you can not share
any of your future plans,
but hopefully
we'll have you back
once all of those secret
future plans are public.
EDWARD WU: Be very
excited to come back.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Thank you.
EDWARD WU: Thank you.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
So, thanks again,
Ed, for such an
interesting interview.
There's so much knowledge.
And I really feel like this
episode could have been
like one hour long, no problem.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: There
was so much to say.
We had to stop it, but
hopefully he'll be back soon.
Who knows?
MARK MANDEL: Hopefully.
Hopefully.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But, yeah.
I hope you enjoyed
the interview.
Let us know if you have
any extra questions,
so we can ask them
directly if you want to.
But it's time to go with
a question of the week.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So, the question of the
week we talked about,
around encryption and data--
encryption of data at rest.
The idea being, so, say
I have these keys, right?
So, I have these
encryption keys that I
want to use for encrypting
my data at rest.
I know Google encrypts
data at rest generally,
but I want to use my own keys.
How can I do that?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
so that is actually
something that happens
often is, sometimes
some companies will have--
they need to have
their own keys.
And they need to be
able to access them.
If you're using Google
Cloud Storage, by default,
it will be encrypted.
But you don't have the choice of
this is the key I want to use.
MARK MANDEL: Yep.
And that's the same
for disks as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
It's actually basically for
every data stored at rest,
is actually encrypted.
So that is pretty cool.
So now what we have is,
there's two options.
Either you manage
completely your keys,
and that is hard, because
you know, it's like--
MARK MANDEL: Security is hard.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Your keys
are kind of an important thing
to keep--
I kept on losing my keys, like
my house keys all the time.
But if you lose your encryption
keys, you know, drama.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah.
And you can't just keep your
encryption keys in a bowl.
Like, that doesn't--
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, that's what I do
and I still lose them.
But anyway, the cool
thing is that we actually
announced recently a new service
which is Google Cloud Key
Management Service.
And what it allows you,
is to have your own keys
that then you can use for the
encryption at rest of your data
on Google Cloud Platform.
But also, you're the
one managing them.
You can create them,
you can rotate them,
you can delete them
if you need to.
And something that I really
like is that, they are also--
this service is linked
directly to IAM.
Which makes it
really easy to manage
who has access to what keys.
And also, it is also
linked to audit logging.
Which means that you not only
can control who access what,
but you can also see
who did access what.
Which is something that
internally at Google we
use, and we know that many
other companies need to use.
So it's very nice to have.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So, actually that's a
really interesting point.
So, I might be--
I definitely have
to have my own keys
and I have to manage
to myself, because
of some requirement or
some sort of audit thing.
But maybe my requirements
are more just like, oh,
you need to make sure you
rotate them this often,
or something like that.
In which case, I could
come to Google Cloud,
use the Key Management
Service, have them manage that
and make that
really easy for me.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
Basically, we understand that
some people, some companies,
have very strict requirements.
And that means that they will
need to manage them themselves,
and that is cool.
But most of the time, the
requirements that they're
going to have will
be met already
by Google Cloud Key
Management Service,
and it makes things just easier.
MARK MANDEL:
Totally fair enough.
All right, cool.
Well, I think that wraps
up our episode though.
But, I know you're about
to do some crazy travel.
Do you want to tell us
where you're going to be
and what you're up to?
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, by the
time this episode comes online,
I will be somewhere in Italy.
I'm going to be in Florence
speaking at Golab.io.
After that I will
go to Barcelona,
hopefully speak at the
Barcelona Go Meetup.
After that, I'll go to
Brussels for FOSDEM.
So if you're going to
be around in FOSDEM,
there's going to
be a Go devroom.
Go there, come say hi.
It's going to be lots of fun.
And after that, I'm off to India
for GopherConIndia in Pune.
I'm almost sure I'm
mispronouncing it,
but I'm going to
keep on saying Pune
until someone says, no, it's
actually Pune or something.
I don't know.
I have no idea.
What about you?
Are you travelling around?
MARK MANDEL: I am
staying in San Francisco,
but still just as busy.
We'll be-- here
in San Francisco,
we're hosting a global game
jam location at our launch pad
space.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Sounds fun.
MARK MANDEL: You can sign
up for that, we still
have some room available.
Then it's basically
all just run up
until the game
developer conference
here in San Francisco.
I'm taking part in the
game developer day.
I'm going to do a lightning
talk there for the Google game
developer day for that.
We have a sponsored
session where
I'm going to be
talking about hosting
basically Unity servers
inside Containers,
and how to do that in the Cloud.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Nice.
MARK MANDEL: Of
course we're going
to be talking about
some big data stuff.
There's a bunch of
stuff going on at GDC,
even more I can talk about.
And then finally, yeah, Next
is coming up after that.
I know you'll be there as well.
FRANCESC CAMPOY:
Cloud Next, it's
going to be pretty awesome.
We will both be speaking
about different topics.
And on top of that, we might
be doing something special
with the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
we'll definitely
have a podcast space.
So we'll be there
with the podcast.
So definitely come
up and say hello.
We will absolutely be there.
Cloud Next is going to be huge.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: Yeah.
I'm very-- I'm between
excited and scared.
MARK MANDEL: I'm terrified.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: But, yeah,
lots of fun, lots of people,
and hopefully many of you
are going to be visiting.
So let us know if you're around.
It's always a
pleasure to meet you.
MARK MANDEL: Absolutely.
FRANCESC CAMPOY: So, I
think that this episode
was long enough to be the
first episode of the year.
So thank you all for listening
to us, and talk to you, Mark,
and to you all, next week.
MARK MANDEL: See
you all next week.
[MUSIC PLAYING]